hey youtubers it's Charlie so it looks
like they've almost found cable for
Deadpool to something to do a breakdown
of the actor they're looking at as well
as Domino because it looks like
Mackenzie Davis might end up being
Domino so here we go
so the big news is that kyle chandler is
being looked at for cable
they're obviously looking at a number of
different actors but the reason kyle
chandler surprise mostly it's just
because of his look he's a really tall
person but he's just not like swole like
cable and when you're looking at cable
in the comics typically you think of
someone who is a giant that Dwarfs
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds is also a very
tall person and even with liberal use of
CG it's hard to show that disparity so I
think that's going to be one of the
departures from the comics like will see
a version of cable that's very true to
the comics but it's not going to be like
the disparity between Colossus and
deadpool because that that's typically
the way you think of cable when you
think of them in the comics you think of
him as being Colossus size because it's
already really big and largely thanks to the work of Rob Liefeld like you can
look at the spider-man picture you can
see how much gear he wears so I think
about how big spider man is this is
cables gear so the joke is that he's
like this walking armory so I'm
expecting them to have some fun with
that idea just you're poking a little
bit of fun at cables depiction in the
comics while also doing all the normal
things that the movie will be doing
they've already said that they're going
to be taking liberal opportunities to
make fun of superhero sequels in general
which is typically something you see
sequel movies do like the best recent
example of a movie making fun of sequels
is the end of 22 jump
street they dedicated their whole post
credit scene to the idea of making fun
of like a billion different sequels to
their one movie so Deadpool isn't going
to be doing that exact thing but they
will be having a lot of fun poking fun
at sequels particularly like the latest
slate of world ending scenario superhero
sequel is like x-men apocalypse Avengers
infinity war batman v superman you get
the idea but let's talk about kyle
chandler so if you're not familiar with
the actor most people know him from
friday night lights but he's been in a
bunch of movies he's primarily a
dramatic actor like he hasn't done a lot
of superhero movies but most of the
characters that he plays the thing that
he's really good at is being the let's
get serious character like friday
night lights is a good example you have
all these crazy teenagers that are
trying to make it through high school
alive, win football games so that's where
most of the drama comes from the coach is
the guy who's like I can't believe all
this shit you guys are getting into we
need to get serious we have a game so
keeping in mind the tone of the first
deadpool movie imagine an utterly
serious character coming in and trying
to kill Deadpool because he does
something that leads to some really
post-apocalyptic terrible world ending
scenario so just to back it up a little
bit if you haven't read a lot of
Deadpool or a lot of cable in the comics
when they first ran into each other
deadpool had been hired to kill cable
and his team of New Mutants that's where
cable showed up for the first time we
didn't know that he was secretly the son
of Scott Summers in Madeline prior who
is kind of like a clone of Jean Grey so
here's where things start to get a
little complicated but cable is a
character that's from the future he time
travels into the past to try and save
the future now they've already done that
in the x-men movies so I'm not expecting
like a copy-paste plot element to the
movie but he comes back into the past to
train this badass team to take down this
future villain called strife who turns
out surprise surprise is a clone of his
in this big plot with mr. sinister and
apocalypse
so you can already see like there's a
lot of crossover with the big x-men
franchise but they said at least for now
Deadpool is going to be a largely
self-contained franchise just because
the tone is so crazy like we want
Deadpool to be able to be deadpool . we
don't want to shoehorn him into a big
x-men movie we just want them to be able
to do all the things that they want to
do with those movies without having to
worry about what's going on in the x-men
franchise but i would expect you just
like with Deadpool one having a whole
bunch of x-men jokes it's not going to
be exactly like the strife arc from the
comics but I'm expecting liberal easter
eggs so like at the beginning of this
big arc back in the nineties cable comes
back into the past to train a badass
team to fight strife but Deadpool gets
hired by another person in the x-men
universe to kill their team then through
the rest of the nineties Deadpool goes
off into his own title they continue to
butt heads
Deadpool's just used is this really
badass wisecracking assassin most people
nowadays when they think of cable
deadpool they think of like a buddy cop
roadtrip flick but they didn't really
start doing that in the comics to more
recently when they were trying to make
the Deadpool character a little more
appealing to younger audiences when he
first debuted he was way more hardcore
there was way more blood now he's used
mostly for comedy but what I'm expecting
is is that the movie will sort of take
all that into account like they will
honor the first time Deadpool met cable
in the comics it'll be like deadpool vs
cable before they have to come together
at the end of the movie in the
relationship resembles the more modern
comics with cable and deadpool so
through it all though cable is still the
utterly serious character he's very Kyle
chandlery so if you're still thinking
Kyle Chandler cable and it sounds kind
of confusing to you like you're like I
don't really see him as cable it's
mostly mostly because physically he
doesn't look like cable forget about
that that's actually relatively easy to
do with a lot of rob liefelding of
his costume it's relatively easy to make
kyle chandler look bigger
it's a lot harder to find a really huge
swole actor they can act really well
that is the problem with Hollywood like
it's really hard to find actors that are
amazing and are also Giants it's the
performance that's hard to nail so
usually when they're looking for actors
for specific roles even in the comic
book movies they usually look for
amazing actors first and then for actors
that sort of kind of fit the physical
description of the role second this is
actually a good example of that but if
you guys don't know boss logic he does a
lot of fanart for really big superhero
things
this is a good example of what Kyle
Chandler might look like as cable butt
is totally gonna be fine
they're shooting the movie early next
year so I would expect them to
officially confirm who is playing cable
by the end of this year at least let me
know in the comments
who do you guys want to see play the
cable character right now
like who do you feel like is an amazing
actor and being like utterly serious but
also doing action because it's a comic
book movie there's gonna be a ton of
action and cable is like a walking
armory and he has to feel like a threat
to Deadpool like he might actually be
able to kill Deadpool you may have also
heard that Mackenzie Davis from halt and
catch fire is being looked at for Domino
that's like a whole
different things so i'll talk about that
in the future Deadpool video but I feel
like she's a pretty amazing actress and
because she's not as big as say like
cable there's not as much of a stigma
attached to the character like there's
not as much baggage that comes with
casting someone for that role so if you
like it's gonna be a lot easier to find
Domino but I am a big fan of Mackenzie
Davis so hopefully she gets the role
this is more boss logic fanart for what
she might actually look like if she gets
it was pretty cool so when related
superhero news there was a whole bunch
of stuff that happened recently james
gunn talked about DC movies that he was
offered but i think it was post
christopher nolan before man of steel
and even bigger than that
Henry Cavill just tease his black
Superman costume from the comics that
he's going to have in justice league so I'll
do Superman black costume Justice League
next that will be my next video be sure
to subscribe to get that and then i'll
do some new punisher because they
confirm punisher season one is coming in
2017 in probably james gunn DC
DC films that he said he was
willing to direct after that so there's
a whole bunch of comic-book DC marvel
stuff happening this week
get hype so why you guys wait for that
to post you can click here to learn more
about the man of steel sequel and you
can click here to learn more about the
Deadpool sequel
thank you so much for watching everybody,
let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight